- Corpus Juris.
Ad hominen tu quoque.
Post hoc ergo propter hoc.
Quod...
I know all of these things,
and it's so hard to say.
Every once in a while
a genius changes the
legal landscape forever.
Sometimes that genius isn't even a lawyer.
And scholars will look back on history
as the days before "The Onion"
filed its Supreme Court brief
and the days after because
we are all changed.
Now, it's not surprising
because according to "The
Onion's" Supreme Court brief,
"'The Onion' rose from
its humble beginnings
"as a print newspaper in 1756
"and now enjoys a daily
readership of 4.3 trillion
"and has grown into the
single most powerful
"and influential organization
in human history."
Yes, "The Onion" has filed
its first ever amicus brief,
and it started with the
top, the U.S. Supreme Court.
Its brief immediately
took law Twitter by storm.
And I've read a lot of briefs in my time,
and trust me, they're not
all as funny and precise
as this one.
And people have asked if real
lawyers were actually involved
in this particular brief.
Yes, the authors of this momentous brief,
"The Onion's" head writer Mike Gillis
and "The Onion's" lawyers of record
Stephen J. van Stempvoort
and D. Andrew Portinga,
who are real people, I
actually checked on that,
pulled no punches in their brief writing.
Quote, "'The Onion' knows
that the federal judiciary
"is staffed entirely by total Latin dorks.
"They quote Catullus in the
original Latin in chambers.
"They sweetly whisper 'stare decisis'
"to their spouse's ears.
"They mutter 'cui bono' under their breath
"while picking up after
their neighbors' dogs.
"So 'The Onion' knew
that unless it pointed
"to a suitably Latin rallying cry,
"its brief would be operating
"far outside the Court's vernacular."
I feel so seen.
But the question must be asked,
is this a great Supreme Court brief
or the greatest Supreme
Court brief in history?
But first we have to ask ourselves,
why is "The Onion" filing
a friend of the court brief
with the Supreme Court?
Well, they're standing
up for Anthony Novak,
an Ohio man who started mocking
his local police department
in March of 2016.
Novak's Facebook page had the same name,
cover photo, and profile photo
as the Parma Police
Department's official page,
but it was designated a community page
and didn't have the official
blue check mark verifying it
as an official page.
Novak's page displayed the
satirical slogan, "We no crime."
Now, Parma is Cleveland,
Ohio's biggest suburb
and it has long had a reputation
for being just a little bit
extra, and by that I mean
it has a well-documented
problem with racism.
In the 1970s, the Justice
Department concluded
that Parma's near-manic
growth was a classic example
of white flight.
The DOJ found that the
city of Parma engaged
in a pattern and practice
of racial discrimination
in housing in violation of
the Fair Housing Act of 1968,
and the city didn't settle
with the DOJ until 1998.
The Parma Police Department has been cited
for refusing to hire
minority police officers.
Cleveland is 51% Black.
Its largest suburb is
still less than 5% Black.
And I'll note parenthetically
that one of the members
of Team LegalEagle is from Cleveland
and informs me that the
Parma police are notorious
for prosecuting drivers
for driving while Black.
Now, legendary public
access host Ghoulardi,
father of director Paul Thomas Anderson,
relentlessly mocked Parma for decades.
Anthony Novak clearly knew this history
when he set out to mock the local cops.
As "Cleveland Magazine" once said, quote,
"Everyone in the country
makes fun of Cleveland,
"and everyone in Cleveland
makes fun of Parma."
Now, Novak's page was up for six hours,
and during that time it
published six satirical posts.
The first was an apology for, quote,
"Failing to inform the
public about an armed robbery
"of a Subway sandwich
shop by a white man,"
while requesting information to, quote,
"bring to justice an
African American woman
"who was loitering in front of
the shop during the robbery."
Novak then published a fake announcement
that new police officers
would be recruited based on a,
quote, "15 question multiple
choice definition test
"followed by a hearing test,
"and strongly encouraged
minorities to not apply."
He followed up with an update
about a pedophile reform event
promising that anyone who
made it through the stations
would be removed from
the sex offender registry
and accepted as an
honorary police officer.
Now by now you are probably thinking
that surely everyone who saw these pages
knew it was a parody
and, of course, was protected
by the First Amendment.
But that's not how the
Parma police saw it.
They got a few phone calls
from confused citizens.
They immediately posted a warning
on the police department's
real page letting people know
that the other page was fake
and that the department was investigating.
The comments to the notice reveal
that most citizens understood
what was happening.
Now, Novak thought it would be funny
to post the police notice
on his page verbatim,
so that's what he did.
Officer Kevin Riley didn't like that,
and so he went on the local news
where he said that the cops
were launching an investigation
into the page's owner.
Riley described the page as, quote-
- But frankly, they're
crude, they're demeaning,
and they're very inflammatory.
Our concern right now is public safety.
- Now as legally idiotic
as those statements were,
Riley's comments did prompt
Novak to take his page down,
but the Parma officials did not let up.
Instead, the police subpoenaed
Facebook to unmask Novak.
The page wasn't even up
by the time that they
discovered Novak's identity.
Now, once they knew it was Novak,
they consulted with the
prosecutor Timothy Dobeck.
Dobeck and the officers
searched for a crime
to fit the situation and ultimately landed
on Ohio Revised Code, Section 2909.04 B,
a felony statute prohibiting
the knowing, quote,
"Use of any computer
to disrupt, interrupt,
"or impair the functions
of any police operation."
Now, how did Novak disrupt
the police department?
His parody caused 11 people
to call up the station in confusion.
But that was enough for a local magistrate
who found that the cops had probable cause
to search Novak's house.
The police then conducted a
SWAT raid on Novak's home,
confiscating his gaming
consoles, computers, and tablets.
Police arrested Novak and threw
him in jail for four days.
Detective Thomas Connor
told the grand jury
that the callers, quote, "honest
to God" actually believed
the page was real.
The grand jury indicted Novak
for disrupting public services,
a fourth degree felony that
carried a maximum penalty
of 18 months in prison.
But not surprisingly,
later during a deposition
Connor admitted that none of the callers
thought the parody Facebook page was real,
but the damage was done.
The city continues to insist to this day
that 10 of those calls wasted
precious dispatch time.
But let's be real,
"Parma dispatchers probably
get more useless phone calls
"when Rudy's Strudel runs
out of donuts on paczki day."
I guess that's a Cleveland joke.
Now, Novak stood trial
and, lucky for him,
the jury acquitted him.
And after he was acquitted, he
then sued the city of Parma,
the police department,
and the police officers
for violating his civil rights,
because that's exactly what they did.
The police officers, not surprisingly,
raised qualified immunity as a defense.
Now, I've talked about
qualified immunity in the past,
but here's a recap of this
judicially invented doctrine.
Qualified immunity
protects state officials
from being held accountable
on a federal level
for violating a person's
constitutional rights.
Under this doctrine, an officer
or state actor is immune
from civil liability if a
court has not previously stated
that the officer's act
was unconstitutional
in a prior court decision.
It's an idea that if there
isn't a court decision
on this type of constitutional violation,
then they don't have notice
that they were violating
someone's constitutional rights.
Now, qualified immunity only
allows lawsuits to move forward
if state officials violated a, quote,
"clearly established statutory
or constitutional right."
And when determining
whether or not a right
was clearly established,
courts consider whether a
hypothetical reasonable officer
would've known that
the defendant's conduct
violated the plaintiff's rights.
What started as a way to ensure
that officials were not held liable
for things that they had no way of knowing
were unconstitutional has now become
really a serious impediment
for holding police officers accountable.
The Federal District
Court for Northern Ohio
denied the Parma officers'
motion for qualified immunity,
but the Sixth Circuit eventually
overturned that decision.
The court held it was
not clearly established
that Novak's copying of
the department's notice
onto his page and the
deletion of user comments
were protected speech.
Under the disruption statute, quote,
"The officers could reasonably believe
"that some of Novak's Facebook
activity was not parody,
"not protected, and fair
grounds for probable cause."
The Sixth Circuit put special value
on the fact that a prosecutor
and magistrate agreed
that there was probable cause
that Novak violated the statute.
Now with that somewhat
depressing background in mind,
we can turn to how in the world
does this involve "The Onion"?
Well, when someone files an amicus brief
they have to start by stating
why they have an interest in the case
that the court should consider.
So the brief starts out by discussing
the interests of the amicus,
the friend of the court,
in this case "The Onion."
Quote, "'The Onion' is the
world's leading news publication
"offering highly acclaimed,
universally revered coverage
"of breaking national, international,
"and local news events."
Quote, "'The Onion's'
keen fact-driven reportage
"has been cited favorably
by one or more local courts,
"as well as Iran and the
Chinese state-run media."
Now, I love this part
because it goes to the heart
of what makes good parody,
the ability of the satirist
to actually make people think
it might be real.
And "The Onion" has tricked many people
into reporting its stories as fact.
And back in 2012, Iran's Fars
News Agency published a story
claiming that a Gallup poll
found that rural white Americans
preferred Iranian President
Mahmoud Ahmadinejad
over President Barack Obama.
Although that feels like
it might have been true,
unfortunately Ahmadinejad was ineligible
for U.S. presidency, so we'll
never know if his stance
about women covering their
hair would've gained traction
in rural Indiana, though
I worry that it would.
Chinese state media also
thought that "The Onion's" story
declaring Kim Jong-Un the
sexiest man alive was real.
"The Onion" wrote that Kim was, quote,
"Blessed with an air of
power that masks (chuckles)
"an unmistakably cute, cuddly side.
"Kim made this newspaper's
editorial board swoon
"with his impeccable fashion
sense, short hairstyle,
"and, of course, that famous smile."
Well, look, when you put it that way,
it's easy to see why the 45th
president had such a crush.
Now, "The Onion" brief also points out
that it has a good track record
of predicting future events.
Quote, "One such coup was
'The Onion's' scoop revealing
"that a former president
kept nuclear secrets
"strewn around his beach home's basement
"three years before it even happened."
Fact check, true. (chuckles)
Now, "The Onion" really
did write a story in 2017
about the nuclear briefcase
being left behind at Mar-a-Lago.
"Noting that it had already
been there for almost two weeks,
"Mar-a-Lago assistant
manager Chris Mahoney
"reportedly wondered if anyone was coming
"to collect the nuclear briefcase
"from the club's lost and found."
Anyway, "The Onion" filed this brief
to protect the rights of parody creators
who, as a class, would
prefer not to be arrested
for being funny.
Quote, "'The Onion' files this brief
"to protect its continued
ability to create fiction
"that may ultimately merge into reality.
"As the globe's premiere parodists,
"'The Onion's' writers also
have a self-serving interest
"in preventing political authorities
"from imprisoning humorists.
"This brief is submitted in the interest
"of at least mitigating
their future punishment."
And the brief zeros in on
the Sixth Circuit's holding
that a parodist would not be protected
unless they let the
audience in on the joke
by warning them that
their parody is not true.
"The Onion" notes that, quote,
"Some forms of comedy don't work
"unless the comedian is
able to tell the joke
"with a straight face.
"Parody is the quintessential example.
"Parodists intentionally
inhabit the rhetorical form
"of their target in order
to exaggerate or implode it,
"and by doing so demonstrate
"the target's illogic or absurdity."
Now, the hilarity of
the brief is an example
of the thing it seeks to
protect: an ultras serious take
on a real thing that by its
nature will fool some people.
Or as "The Onion's" lawyers put it, quote,
"For parody to work,
"it has to plausibly mimic the original."
And as "The Onion" points
out in its brief, quote,
"Tu stultus es. You are dumb.
"These Latin words have
been 'The Onion's' motto
"and guiding light since
it was founded in 1988
"as America's finest news source,
"leading its writers toward
the paper's singular purpose
"of pointing out that its readers
"are deeply gullible people."
And they're not just crapping
on their own audience.
They're making an important
point that, quote,
"Tricking readers into believing
"that they're seeing a serious rendering
"of some specific form,
"a pop song lyric, a newspaper
article, a police beat,
"and then allowing them to
laugh at their own gullibility
"when they realize that
they've fallen victim
"to one of the oldest tricks
in the history of rhetoric."
And despite the literal
falsity of parody and satire,
it literally has to be false to work,
it enjoys First Amendment
protection, as it should.
And when assessing whether
satirical speech is defamation,
the courts consider
what a reasonable reader
would've understood the
author to have said,
not the literal meaning of the words.
And the capacity to fool
the audience is essential.
So in other words, a person...
Billy.
No, you can't be up here.
So in other words, a person
doesn't have to publish
a disclaimer that the writing is fake.
That would ruin the joke.
Imagine how it would've
ruined the punchline
of Jonathan Swift's "A Modest Proposal"
which argued with a straight face
that the starving Irish should
just eat their own babies.
And if you're worried about
"The Onion" being humble
in comparing itself to Jonathan Swift,
well, you don't need to be.
They write, quote, "To be clear,
"'The Onion' is not
trying to compare itself
"to Jonathan Swift.
"Its writers are far more talented
"and their output will be read long after
"that hack Swift's has been
lost to the sands of time.
"Still, 'The Onion' and its
writers share with Swift
"the common goal of replicating a form
"precisely in order to
critique it from within."
And as "The Onion" points out,
Swift's goals was the same,
to replicate the form,
the boring economic paper,
in order to critique it from within.
And that's why the full
title of Swift's paper
was "A Modest Proposal for
Preventing the Children
"of Poor People from Being
a Burden to Their Parents
"or Country and for Making
Them Beneficial to the Public."
And "The Onion" writers do this every day
to hilarious effect.
The brief points to an
"Onion" article titled, quote,
"The Supreme Court Rules
Supreme Court Rules,"
which is meant to mimic the
form of "The Associated Press."
It starts with the sentence,
"In a landmark decision Monday,
"the United States Supreme
Court ruled 8-1 that it rules."
And "The Onion" follows
"The Associated Press" form
straight through into the article.
It says, quote, "Justice Anthony Kennedy,
"writing on behalf of the
majority, noted that, quote,
"'while the U.S. Constitution
guarantees equality of power
"among the executive, legislative,
and judicial branches,
"it most definitely does not guarantee
"equality of coolness,
"and in this regard, the
judicial branch kicks
"that which can be construed
as total and complete ass.'"
So the power of the parody
rises from that dissonance
into which the reader has been drawn.
And "The Onion's" brief argues
that because parody mimics the real thing
it has even more power to
critique the real thing.
Quote, "Parodists can take apart
"an authoritarian's cult of personality,
"point out the rhetorical tricks
"that politicians use to
mislead their constituents,
"and even undercut a
government institution's
"real world attempts at propaganda."
For "The Onion," this has
worked time and time again
since its articles tend to expose leaders
who have no ability to
distinguish fact from fiction.
The brief singles out one of them,
Republican Congressman
John Fleming, who, quote,
"Believed that he needed
to warn his constituents
"of a dangerous escalation
of the pro-choice movement
"after reading 'The Onion's' headline,
"'Planned Parenthood Opens
$8 Billion Abortionplex.'"
Of course, Yelp reviewers
got in on the gag
and reviewed the fake Kansas Abortionplex,
which convinced other readers
that this was a real thing
and, quote, "We taxpayers,
we're paying for it."
The legendary Abortionplex story
is still fooling people in 2022.
And although the brief tongue-in-cheek
called "Onion" readers stupid,
it backtracks on that claim
in explaining the mental
capacity of reasonable readers
who, quote, "Do not need
to be told explicitly
"what they have no serious trouble
"figuring out for themselves."
And the brief notes that the Supreme Court
has already indicated that
disclaimers aren't needed.
They refer to a footnote
of the opinion of Campbell
versus Acuff-Rose,
which, of course, was a
very famous fair use case
where the dispute was
about whether the rap group
2 Live Crew had a right
to publish a parody
of Roy Orbison's "Pretty Woman."
And in that case, the
court said that 2 Live Crew
need not label their whole
album or even the song a parody
in order to claim fair use protection,
nor should 2 Live Crew be penalized
for this being its first parodic essay.
♪ Big hairy woman ♪
♪ You need to shave that stuff ♪
- Parody serves its goals,
whether labeled or not,
and there's no reason to require
parody to state the obvious
or even the reasonably perceived.
And "The Onion" argues convincingly
that the Sixth Circuit's holding
is contrary to the case law.
The court ruled that
the Parma cops, quote,
"Could reasonably believe
"that some of Novak's Facebook
activity was not parody,
"primarily because Mr.
Novak deleted comments
"that made clear the page was fake."
But the brief argues that the
lack of explicit disclaimer
makes no difference to
whether a reasonable reader
would discern that this speech was parody.
And "The Onion" takes issue
with the Sixth Circuit's view
that the search warrants
insulates the police
from liability since other
authority figures also share
the same wrongheaded view of free speech.
Quote, "This was not a
close call on the facts.
"Mr. Novak's spoof
Facebook posts advertised
"that the Parma Police
Department was hosting
"a pedophile reform event
"in which successful
participants could be removed
"from the sex offender registry
"and become honorary
members of the department
"after completing puzzles and quizzes;
"that the department had discovered
"an experimental technique for abortions
"and would be providing
them to teens for free
"in a police van;
"that the department was
soliciting job applicants,
"but that minorities were, quote,
"'strongly encouraged' not to apply;
"and that the department
was banning city residents
"from feeding homeless
people in, quote, 'an attempt
"to have the homeless population
eventually leave our city
"due to starvation.'"
So yeah, you'd have to
be pretty dumb to think
that the Facebook posts
were real and also criminal.
Novak can't help it if a magistrate judge
and city attorney are closer
to the lowest common denominator
than the average reasonable reader.
And "The Onion" also argues
that parodists should not be
prosecuted for telling jokes.
Now this seems self-explanatory,
so "The Onion" lawyers
crafted a couple paragraphs
just to keep your attention.
Quote, "This is the 15th page
of a convoluted legal filing
"intended to deconstruct
"the societal implications of parody,
"so the reader's attention is
almost certainly wandering.
"That's understandable.
"So here's a paragraph of
gripping legal analysis
"to ensure that every
jurist who reads this brief
"is appropriately impressed
by the logic of its argument
"and the lucidity of its pros.
"Bona vacantia.
"De bonis asportatis.
"Writ of certiorari.
"De minimus.
"Jus accrescendi.
"Forum non conveniens.
"Corpus Juris.
"Ad hominem tu quoque.
"Post hoc ergo propter hoc.
"Quod..."
I know all of these things,
and it's so hard to say.
"Quod est demonstrandum.
"Actus reus.
"Scandalum magnatum.
"Pactum reservati dominii.
"See what happened?
"This brief itself went from a discussion
"of parody's function and
the quite serious historical
"and legal arguments in
favor of strong protections
"for parodic speech to a curve
ball mocking the way legalese
"can be both impenetrably boring
"and belie the hollowness
of a legal position.
"That's the setup and
punchline idea again.
"It would not have worked quite as well
"if this brief had said the following:
"'Hello there, reader, we're
about to write an amicus brief
"about the value of parody.
"Buckle up, because
we're going to be doing
"some fairly outre things,
"including commenting on
this text's form itself.'"
So yeah, it's not good
to punish funny people
for saying funny things,
even if those things may be offensive.
And "The Onion" promises to, quote,
"Continue its socially valuable role
"bringing the disinfectant of sunlight
"into the halls of power.
"And it would vastly prefer
"that sunlight not be
measured out to its writers
"in 15 minute increments
in an exercise yard."
And this YouTube channel agrees.
Now normally a lawyer's
conclusion is a pretty dry summary
of what they want the court to do,
but here "The Onion" aims high once again.
Quote, "The petition for
certiorari should be granted,
"the rights of the people vindicated,
"and various historical wrongs remedied.
"'The Onion' would
welcome any of the three,
"particularly the first."
So what happens next?
Well, the Supreme Court will decide
whether to take Novak's case or not
and potentially overturn the
Sixth Circuit's decision.
If it does not,
then the Sixth Circuit
decision remains good law
despite it being bad law.
But you'll be able to read
all about the Supreme
Court's next decision
in today's sponsor, Morning Brew,
because that's my favorite way to catch up
with pop culture and the news.
In fact, you could have already learned
about "The Onion's" brief
because they covered it
and I read it in my email.
I've actually been subscribed
to Morning Brew for forever.
It's one of my absolute
favorite newsletters,
and I'm thrilled to tell you why.
Because Morning Brew, if
you didn't know already,
is a free daily newsletter
delivered Monday through Sunday.
It gets you up to speed on
business, finance, tech, and law
in just five minutes and provides
a fantastic quick summary
of the most important issues
while being witty,
irreverent, and informative.
And did I mention it's completely free?
This week I learned
all about how Elon Musk
actually bought Twitter
for real this time,
how Kanye West was getting
denounced by everyone,
and why Matt Damon killed
everyone's investment returns.
It's basically exactly the mix of news
that I'm actually interested in
and stuff that I didn't even
know I wanted to know about,
and it's all written in a hilarious style.
Morning Brew is one of the few emails
that I actually open every day.
So LegalEagles, this one
is a complete no-brainer.
Morning Brew is completely free
and it takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe.
Just click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description to
get Morning Brew for free.
And not only will you get a newsletter
that you'll actually read,
you'll actually help out this channel too.
So click on the link below to
get Morning Brew right away.
And after you sign up,
you should click over here
on this playlist to watch more LegalEagle,
or I'll see you in court.